let's jump into this first story from
timcast.com Marco Rubio canvas are
reportedly attacked told Republicans not
allowed in the neighborhood he was he
was also campaigning for DeSantis as
well I believe he was wearing a Rubio
hat and his hand his shirt or I'm sorry
he was wearing a DeSantis hat and a
Rubio shirt the campaign volunteer who
was wearing apparel supportive of the
Florida Senator and the Florida governor
DeSantis reportedly suffered internal
bleeding and will require facial
reconstructive surgery Rubio reported on
Monday hylia mayor Esteban Steve bovo
said the police department has
reportedly made an arrest though did not
provide further details setting a lack
of information the Miami Herald reported
so apparently I mean Rubio's saying it
was four guys now this is where it gets
fun
because Charlie Chris has come out
himself and I can respect this this is
the Democrat running for governor saying
there's no place for violence in
politics Senator Rubio your canvasser is
in our prayers and we look forward to
those responsible being brought to
Justice we have Val Deming saying I have
zero tolerance for any violence against
any person for any reason those
responsible for our taking a canvasser
last night should be arrested and
prosecuted the fullest extent of the law
now I absolutely uh can respect those
calling this out
um the Democrats calling this out the
violence but here's here's I just gotta
here we go from the Miami New Times
Rubio supporter attacked while
canvassing is identified has apparent
white supremacist past okay now the
first thing is a bunch of leftists
pointed this out antifa came out and
said he deserved it they were tweeting
this saying that oh it turns out he was
a white supremacist therefore he
deserves it I think he's Cuban and he's
not white so I don't know if white
supremacists makes sense you know you
can call him something else I guess what
if you want to call him fascist so this
guy gets it's mercilessly beaten and the
left immediately finds a justification
for why I can only assume then they're
probably the ones who beat him and this
was their justification but uh the first
thing I'm going to say yeah I don't like
his opinions if that's the case you know
I've seen some screenshots of things he
may have posted they're accusing him of
posting really really awful stuff some
of the worst of the worst does not
justify mercilessly beating someone to
the point where they need surgery and
they're internally bleeding and then I
want to point out if the Democrats want
to play keep playing games like this we
could now say
Governor uh governor candidate Charlie
Crist defended white supremacists today
that's the game they play in the media
so if they want to come out and attack
this guy who was just beaten and try and
make it seem like there's justification
for it then we can point out oh
Democrats are defending white
supremacists right the simple thing is
no violence condemn it all the dude can
say bad things I don't think it's
relevant to why he was brutally beaten
right right now this is the kind of
stuff we have to call for de-escalation
on I just think it's crazy that they
they're always the right is the real
threat to America or democracy or
anything but if we look at these attacks
over and over again it's always
conservatives that are getting run over
by cars or beaten to a bloody pulp or
Rand Paul's getting attacked by his
neighbor it's it's it's not them that
are getting brutalized all the time it's
our side that's getting this all the
time there's a video going viral right
now of well I will point out just for
the sake of I can hear all the leftists
screaming Charlottesville when you know
James Fields I think he ran I have my
own theory on that but that's fine and
like if you actually watch the footage
but but I mean you know there's there's
a lot to say Andy does tend to be the
one and BLM and these left extremists
going around causing all the violence
and there's a video right now that that
I retweeted where it's like a guy and
his girlfriend I'm assuming they're
walking and antifa's beating them and
then even an anti-thematic grabs the
woman and she's screaming and I'm like
that's an important thing to highlight
for people is that the antifa people
will put red crosses on their arms
for two reasons it's a disguise so they
can go and beat people and go I'm just a
medic and then when the pl and then and
then also is propaganda when the police
arrest them then they post for saying
the police are arresting medic so why
are they doing it and it's because
they're psychotic extremist terrorists
who are beating people
I'm looking at the the the article that
you mentioned here I'm trying to find
out the exact sources of what they're
using here but they're also reporting
that the police report is not mentioning
that there was a political dispute nor
does it look or indicate that there was
a specific targeting of this specific
individual so so what's really going on
here are they just trying to justify it
was there any reason is there someone
really going through Twitter finding
someone on the street that's a niche
person saying hey you did this in a
couple years ago I highly doubt that uh
exactly no one's saying that I I know I
know what they're saying is this guy was
canvassing some people saw his shirt in
his hat beat him up and then when the
news broke from Rubio that this guy was
was brutally beaten and told you're not
supposed to be here antifa immediately
rushed out to dig up the guy's past now
here's the other issue I don't know
that's even true because the photos they
posted do not look like this guy unless
he dropped 50 pounds yeah he looks like
a Spanish guy too which doesn't really
add up to a good you know white
supremacist there in the story that they
have there so so again a lot of the
things don't make sense here we don't
know exactly what happened we weren't
there there's not there's no video of
the incident but we have to understand
that our society is becoming more
violent when we look at crimes
especially in major cities there is an
epidemic happening here and whether it's
because of the destruction of our mental
health or just our political class
becoming more hyperbolic by the day it
was just a few weeks ago where Biden
stood behind a huge Podium with the red
lights behind him declaring that that
Maga people are the true danger to this
country and when you have such
sensationalistic hyperbolic language
you're going to have people taking
action on that language which is pretty
dangerous for everyone involved in the
political sphere another interesting
point though to bring up is that they
can always dig into the past of
Republicans too but like it didn't
matter about George George Floyd's past
right like he did he can hold guns to
pregnant women and that's fine any point
that gun like at her belly yeah I read I
don't know is that what he did yeah
and robbed her I I read that he pointed
the gun at her belly and said do you
want your baby to live or die right
right he's fine we can we can I've also
realized that story was completely
fabricated so I don't know what to think
and it's really irrelevant we know that
he had a criminal record that's we know
that he was like drugs when he died we
don't even know what they're saying
about this guy is true I didn't read any
of like the tweets that it says but even
if it were it didn't seem to matter for
their people with their Shady pasts
right and so it doesn't justify violence
it under any destruction yeah it's
always something funny you know I went
to this Market the other day and it was
really really great it was in um Potomac
Virginia I think it's is the name of the
city it's beautiful place wow everyone
there is very wealthy The Mall At
Tyson's I could not believe it was like
being in the capital city of The Hunger
Games the bathroom had like a lounge
section in it like like it was weird
like a half moon chair and and there's
like weird like marble lighting wow and
I went to this market and they had a uh
some Ruth Bader Ginsburg chocolates and
it said uh notorious RBG and you know I
said that is a perfect gift for Luke and
so I bought it and I brought it back to
Luke the reason I bring it up is that
one of the chocolates it said something
like fight for what you believe in with
the red salute on it the Communist Fist
and I just think it's funny like I know
what the red salute is and means and why
what the symbol is supposed to be but
you see it as a mainstream icon and this
one I I know the left is gonna love this
one they're gonna start vomiting on
themselves screaming when I see the red
salute it may as well be a swastika
right there were two extremist
ideologies in Europe the turn of the
19th century they believed almost the
same things in terms of authoritarianism
they just differed on cultural things
the Communists wanted to purge the
culture the Nazis wanted to reinforce
traditional culture but they both loved
the symbol of the week coming together
to form the strong with the fascists
they had the fascists the bundle of
sticks with the with the blade in it
strapped together because each
individual stick is weak but together
makes a weapon and the red salute is the
outward facing fist where each
individual finger is weak but together
it's strong that's why they're showing
you the fingers when they do it so when
I go into a store and it's a bunch of
like regular old people being like we're
normal people who don't like extremism
here's our hate symbol you know here's
here's here's a here's a chocolate with
a symbol of of a hundred million dead
and it's normal to people it's
completely normal yeah I was like uh
thank you Tim for the genocide of my
people on chocolate since of course you
know I'm polish I was born and raised in
Poland and that represents you know a
lot of you know just horrible things
that that happened to my people uh the
the all the innocent people that were of
course tortured that were murdered
because they didn't believe in the right
political ideas then of course the
Communists wanted you to believe in and
I think there's a reason why there's so
much genocide and so much communism that
always coalesces together throughout
human history and that's something that
is not really taught in in history class
or in public schools but but there's a
big correlation there and it's not an
accident but the point that you're
making to where it's like all these rich
people and whatever I think we should
just James cloak he was doing a like
what is fascism or is America fascist
type of video and there's all these like
rich people on the beach and and he's
pushing them against like about what is
fascism they have no idea what it even
means they can't Define it right so
they're going around calling like all
Americans or at least half the
population fascists they they don't even
know what it means well here's a funny
thing I watched this YouTube video so I
went to Gettysburg this weekend too and
then you know it's it's a it's like an
hour and 40 minutes or whatever from
your hour and a half and then uh started
watching a documentary series like four
hours long and then in between that
YouTube recommended this what would
happen a video from a YouTuber I forgot
his name so I apologize for this guy but
it was like who would win a Civil War
and it was a really great video he got a
lot of things wrong oh you're talking
about what if all history yeah that guy
that red yard he's been he's been asking
in the show a couple times here people
have been asking oh okay I watched his
videos really really interesting thing
and uh I forgot exactly what I was
trying to say about it what were you
what were you just mentioning Gettysburg
and civil war Civil War no no what were
you saying about the rich people not
knowing what like what fascism is and oh
right right right I'm sorry sorry the
point he made is that uh prior to the
past 50 years every political faction
was authoritarian right the the idea
that there is an authoritarian left is
new that the idea there's a Libertarian
left is extremely new and so he he was
making this point where he's like if you
were to take all the political factions
from like the previous conflicts
throughout the past hundred years and
bring them to today they would all be
authoritarian right like even the
Communists were very pro-masculinity and
like working class they just wanted to
purge the traditions and the fascists
wanted to preserve the Traditions right
but they were all like like lunatic
homicidal maniacs and the funny thing I
think about it is it's just like really
easy to point out as like we know the
Nazis were some of the worst in in in in
in in our history like just the
horrifying things they did and the
Communists did what 10 12-fold more
substantially more than that right right
yeah oh yeah like like 50 times yep the
Communists all together had like 50
times more murder and genocide right but
it's always it's always an awesome but
you can buy the red salute in your local
Town Market on a chocolate supporting
your Supreme Court your favorite Supreme
Court Justice did Obama have like a a
Christmas ball with Mal on it in the
White House
I'm not sure about that I don't know
we've got to look that way look that up
I'm just I I feel like I feel like that
was a thing and that was a long time I
remember when I pointed out some some
leftists did the thread salute I mean
they all do it they walk around they
raise the fist they don't understand
that the raising the fist is literally I
I think it was like Ethan Klein or
somebody it was like Tim's criticizing
the universal symbol of resistance and
I'm like that's not what it is like yo
read a history book bro it's the red
salute the Chinese Communist party when
you're when you're joining it you have
to give the red salute while you recite
the pledge to the Chinese Communist
party it's like imagine if imagine
imagine if you you could like buy a
chocolate with a Roman salute on it it's
just it's just Bonkers that that's
acceptable in this country we're a
country of like Freedom loving
libertarian individualist types that's
that's what the country is founded on
yet authoritarian murderous genocidal
communism has their symbols everywhere
and uh I think you're right Fox News has
an article from 2015 that's titled White
House Christmas decor featuring Mao
zetang comes Under Fire and it talks
about how how Mao zingtong was hanging
out with a drag queen in the in the
depiction there
um it's again an old article but yeah it
was like a really long time ago but
that's okay in the in the white house
it's kind of crazy to see so many
genociders just uh publicly loved and
adored especially Che Guevara when you
look at his history especially the way
he treated people in the lgbtq TQ
Community especially how he treated
people of color uh the history on that
when you look at it is very eye-opening
to say the least what do we think of the
Trudeau mention of his love of Communism
no like the the comparison that what's
the space is his father oh like it's
like this I mean the pictures are funny
the pictures are funny yeah I mean and
that's like there's weird history that
aligns this you know like I like my
conspiracy didn't this mother meet I
think that's what it was yeah like
numerous times I I think it's funny
because like I was reading a Snopes
thing and it's like Trudeau's mother did
beat with Castro and it was around the
top like it was like in a similar time
frame to when he may have been you know
born or whatever but I think they're
saying it was a couple years before
anyway they they look quite a bit alike
yeah he doesn't look like his father
so it doesn't look like he doesn't
that's for sure yeah no he's clearly
fond of the ideology so maybe Fidel
Castro was a Milkman in Canada yeah you
know maybe he's
he's trying to grab onto his like his
father's Legacy I don't know it's the
funniest things about these things where
it's like well it is true that Trudeau
does look like him and he doesn't look
like his father and his mother did meet
Castro and did travel down there
it's debunked it's it's not and you're
like well what do you mean like do you
have any evidence like you're you're
giving like there's a thing snopes is
giving us reason to believe it's
actually true not not necessarily stuff
to these other a bunch of fact checks
it's like all these points you're making
about you know coincidence and
happenstance our evidence
in the positive and then you just come
out right and say but it doesn't
actually make sense therefore it's
debunked we see that so often with fact
checks in the media
well yeah they just they just they just
pick and choose whatever they want to of
course work for their larger agenda I
did hear that the years don't add up and
that the year that the photos that are
circulating uh don't add up to when he
was born there's other people arguing it
was IVF yeah I don't know how advanced
was that at the time I don't know if
they had that during that time he's not
that special but there's other people
packaged on dry ice delivered to the
Trudeau household yeah
it doesn't match up for that time that
she met him like there's plenty of
people that still see people without
anybody knowing yeah the other people
are arguing that there was specific
meetings that happened between them a
whirlwind not documented or I mean
internet of course Fidel I can't do this
my husband will find out this needs to
be made into a soap opera I liked it
yeah I'm just gonna keep trying to
believe that it's true The General
elissimo
no my son it's not my son thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there